we are
black folks in this country that are all
we're doing
is saying our lives matter we're not
asking for more than somebody else is
asking for
we want our children to grow up we want
to survive we want to have the same
quality of life
welcome back to cbs this morning that's
missouri congresswoman corey bush
reacting to the conviction of derek
chovin for the murder of george floyd
bush got into politics
in response to the 2014 death of
18-year-old michael brown
who was killed by a ferguson missouri
police officer
president obama's justice department
found darren wilson
shot brown in self-defense the massive
protests in the city also
inspired others to get involved in the
streets and in government
including fran griffin our national
correspondent jerica duncan watched
yesterday's chauvin verdict in ferguson
with the former activist turned city
councilwoman
when law reads the verdict says they
will appear on the permanent record
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony
find the defendant guilty it took a
second for the word guilty to sink in
perpetrating an eminently dangerous act
find the defendant guilty
creating an unreasonable risk find the
defendant guilty
but after hearing it three times tears
of joy
are these your true and cried and a
moment to herself
even take it for a minute as we waited
at the kitchen table
griffin sobbed from her bedroom when she
returned she told us why
april 20 2021 changed the history
of this nation we got to hold someone
accountable
a police officer who killed
an unarmed black man
he was held accountable today to me
it's kind of shocking because i never
seen nobody
actually guilty what does this mean for
your sons
your two black sons if anything it gives
them
confidence that they can actually create
the change minutes after the verdict the
text messages and
calls poured in phone's buzzing you want
to answer it yeah
hello guilty on all charges yes
griffin says she wasn't sure what to
expect
in 2014 she stood with protesters in
ferguson
after then officer darren wilson shot
and killed michael brown
a mile from her home no probable cause
exists to file any charge against
officer wilson
wilson and other witnesses testified
brown punched him in the face
before he shot brown when a grand jury
decided not to indict wilson
griffin watched as parts of her city
went up in flames
in 2019 she defeated a long-term
incumbent to become the city's first
black councilwoman to represent the
third ward
griffin has been on the front lines
pushing for more police training
and accountability from officers she
hopes yesterday's verdict
is not the exception every time we go
through this process
like it
it's traumatizing it's triggering
you don't know which way it's going to
go everybody's holding their breath
for them to find him
guilty on all three charges it does give
you
just a few moments to take a breath
then we gotta finish working
griffin who is the mother of three has a
14 year old an 18 year old and 21 year
old said yesterday was also about
showing the youth
what is possible when it comes to
creating change saying quote
the younger they get the message the
harder they will fight
to achieve it and i also just want to
mention the symbolism
yesterday it was snowing it was freezing
out here
and when we left miss fran's home the
sun
had come out also she has a cute little
dog that
had was in other rooms before the
verdict came out and right before
moments before that little dog came
running in almost
as if the dog even knew that something
big was about to happen and was coming
wow yeah rodrigo that's an amazing
conversation incredible to capture the
moment we've seen the jubilation the
cheers and with fran
the quiet recognition to see it slowly
sink in
slowly sinking very powerful stuff
edrica thank you very much